I'm dancing with the stars monday night
meteorologist ginger Zee bravely opened
up about her battle with anorexia 10 to
14 was the the bulk of my anorexia I
don't think I even knew how how bad it
was at that time how did it feel to you
to talk about that on television it felt
strange to be honest so that's not
something that I shared too often I
think it's a disease that you choose
unfortunately but it chooses a lot of
people you know and a lot of the young
girls especially deal with it and I hope
that I can just tell them you don't have
to be stuck there ginger said she will
always deal with body shaming and opened
up to me about another struggle mom
shaming have you experienced that being
on the show balancing all the things
you're balancing we're all doing our
best like I don't know a mother who's
saying you know what I'm gonna suck at
being a mom today they're not so I don't
know why someone would ever attack but
of course they do so you have gotten
comments like since pmish ash oh
definitely people are not you know
people are not nice and you know and but
that's other thing is you don't hear the
nice stuff always you hear the negative
and so I always try to just do my best
know that I'm doing you know great at
what I do and then thank them for their
opinion
you